we've already spent a lot of time
thinking about these six different
scenarios all of which sit on the
production possibilities frontier which
means that in any of these scenarios we
have achieved productive efficiency and
it's true not just of these scenarios
it's true of any of the points on this
curve so you have achieved any point on
that curve productive
productive let me give ourselves some
real estate on the right productive
efficiency
productive efficiency let me write
productive efficiency
efficiency
which means or one another way to think
about it is that at one at as soon as
you're at any point on that curve if you
want any more of one of these things you
have to give up some of the other so for
example if you're at point c and if you
want more rabbits if you want one more
rabbit you're going to have to give up
you're going to have to give up some
berries or if you're at point c and you
want more berries you want more berries
you're going to have to give up some
rabbits so any and that's true of any
point on the production possibilities
frontier a point over here let me do
this in a different color
so let's say that this point right over
here you have not achieved productive
efficiency here because you can get more
rabbits you can get more rabbits without
having to give up any berries and you
could get to scenario b or you could get
more berries you could get more berries
and not have to give up any rabbits and
you would get to scenario d so this
right over here is inefficient
in efficient
now
all of these that's all good all of
these fives and or six scenarios we've
achieved productive efficiency but which
of these do we pick how do we decide to
allocate our time so what i want to talk
about in this video is allocative
efficiency
allocative
allocative efficiency
and it's somewhat subjective based on
the preferences of if we are the
hunter-gatherer based on our preferences
but at least it gives us a framework for
thinking which of these meets our
preferences the best
and to do that i will review a little
bit from the last video in the last
video we talked about the marginal cost
of each incremental rabbit or we said
the opportunity cost of each incremental
rabbit and the opportunity cost of one
incremental unit that really is just the
marginal cost so let's just write these
different scenarios
so these are the so let's write the
scenarios
scenario for short scene for short and
then let's think about the marginal cost
of one incremental rabbit
of i'll just draw a rabbit here of one
incremental rabbit and it's going to be
given in berries
so in berries
in
berries
in berries
all right let's start with scenario f
and this is all review from the last
video sitting in scenario f if we want
if we want to get one extra rabbit we
are going to have to give up we are
going to have to give up 20 berries
in scenario e if we're sitting in
scenario e and we want even one more
rabbit we now have to give up we now
have to give up 40 berries
so the marginal cost of that the
marginal cost at that point of one more
one more i keep wanting to say squirrel
one more rabbit is 40 berries now let's
go to scenario d
scenario d and i encourage you to pause
and do this yourself it'll help if you
kind of work it out
scenario d the cost of one extra rabbit
is now is now 60 berries
is now 60 berries you go to scenario c
the cost is now the cost is now 80
berries so in crc the cost is now 80
berries finally go to scenario b
and the cost of sitting in scenario b of
getting one extra rabbit you're going to
have to give up
100 you're going to have to give up 100
berries and i won't even go into
scenario a because it will be impossible
for you to have any more rabbits and you
have no more berries to give up so these
are all the possible scenarios and the
marginal costs of them and we can
actually plot them on a line so let me
do that right over here this will be
useful
so
let me draw
one axis right over here
one axis over here and this is let's
let's call this the different scenarios
so
this let me do the same order let's call
this scenario f
scenario f scenario e
i'm just doing one color right now
scenario e scenario d
scenario c
and scenario and scenario b actually let
me instead of doing it that way let me
just talk about it in terms of the
number of squirrels i have
so the number of squirrels that i have
so in scenario f
if you remember in scenario f not
squirrels rabbits in scenario f you have
zero rabbits scenario f you have zero
rabbits so let's say zero
one
two
three
four
and five and so this is the number of
rabbits
not squirrels
the number of rabbits that you that you
right now are able to catch on average
each day
and then in the vertical axis in the
vertical axis
right now
i want to put the marginal cost the
marginal cost in berries
in berries and let's see it goes from 20
up to 100 so let's say that this is so
this is 20
and 100. so scenario f
that's when we had zero rabbits and the
marginal cost of getting the marginal
cost of trying to get another rabbit
you'd have to give up 20 berries so that
is scenario f right over there scenario
scenario e
that's one where we had one
where we already had one rabbit and we
are thinking about the marginal cost of
getting another one so that scenario e
is right over there this is scenario d
marginal cost is 60. we already have two
rabbits and we're thinking about getting
a third that's scenario d
and then scenario c
scenario c we already have three rabbits
thinking about getting a fourth that's
scenario c and then finally we have
scenario b where we already have four
rabbits and we think we're we're
thinking about getting a fifth and we
would have to give up a hundred berries
to get that fifth to get that fifth
rabbit so that's scenario b right over
there so what i've just done is plotted
the marginal cost along these are points
on our essentially our marginal cost
curve our marginal cost as a function of
the number of rabbits we have so let me
connect all the dots and in this
scenario just happen to be a line
doesn't always have to be a line but in
many introductory economics courses it's
often a line for simplicity so let me
make this let me just make this a line
right over here this is our marginal
cost as a function of the number of
rabbits we have and actually i should
probably draw this axis i should
probably draw let me let me copy and
paste this so let me cut this
so let me cut
that and then let me paste it
because it really should sit on the zero
point right over there
right over there and ignore that little
that little that little line right over
there
so there you have marginal cost as a
function of berries but we still don't
know which scenario to pick and to think
about that i want to introduce something
called the marginal benefit
so the marginal benefit
the marginal i'll write it as mb the
marginal benefit
of the marginal benefit of an
incremental rabbit
and once again we're going to write it
in berries and the way to think about
the marginal benefit is if we are the
hunter gatherer we're saying if we're
sitting in one of these scenarios how
much would we pay to some hypothetical
convenience store in berries maybe that
can be store only sells only sells
bunnies and they only accept berries how
much would we pay to them in berries for
an extra rabbit
so and let's not even look at this thing
right over here so if we're sitting in
scenario f we're sitting in scenario f
and you remember scenario f is right
over here we have no rabbits how much
would we be willing to pay we have no
rabbits and we actually have a ton of
berries so in scenario f right here we
have no rabbits and we have 300 berries
if we have no rabbits and a lot of
berries let's say we'll say well we have
a lot of berries we might be in the mood
for a rabbit we'd be willing to pay a
lot in berries for a rabbit so let's say
we would pay a hundred
we would pay
we would pay a hundred a hundred berries
to that that that hypothetical
convenience store for a rabbit
now let's say that we're in scenario e
we're in scenario e how much would we
pay to that hypothetical convenience
store well in scenario e we already have
one rabbit and we have fewer berries so
we need a rabbit less and we have fewer
berries to give so we're not willing to
give quite as many berries for another
rabbit so maybe we'll only give 80
berries then you go to scenario c
scenario d we already have two rabbits
and we have even fewer berries so we're
willing to give even fewer berries for
another rabbit this is what we would pay
to a convenience store just based on
thinking about it our current
preferences then we can go all the way
to scenario c and it is subjective it's
not like a measurable thing it's just
based on this person's preferences this
hunter gathers preferences
scenario c
well even more they already have more
rabbits even fewer bun even fewer
berries so they'll pay even less and
then finally scenario b
they have a good number of rabbits and
even fewer berries they would be willing
to pay they'd be very willing to pay
very little for an incremental for an
incremental rabbit so let's plot the
marginal benefit as a function of the
number of rabbits that they already have
so if we go to scenario f the marginal
benefit doing that little thought
experiment is a hundred
in scenario e the marginal benefit how
much you would hypothetically be willing
to pay in berries is now 80 berries in
scenario d it is 60 berries in scenario
c
it is 40 berries so scenario c is right
over here so in scenario c is 40 berries
and then in scenario b
it is 20 berries it is 20 berries so in
scenario b it is 20 berries just like
that so now we're not just plotting the
marginal cost we're plotting the
marginal cost and the marginal benefit
in berries and the marginal benefit
curve
and it's really a line here once again
for simplicity looks like that
now given this so this is the marginal
benefit curve marginal benefit as a
function of the number of rabbits that
we already have and this is the marginal
cost as a function of the number of
rabbits we already have and so when i
say e this is actually situation e
that's situation d this is also
situation c and this is also this is the
marginal benefit at situation b
so given this what would i rationally do
if these really are my preferences what
would i rationally do so if i'm sitting
here in in situation f i have no rabbits
i i already know that it would cost me
20 rabbits to try to get to try to get
an incremental one but i've already said
that i'd be willing to pay a hundred
sorry it would cost me 20 berries to get
an incremental rabbit but i've already
said that i'm willing to pay a hundred
berries to get an incremental rabbit so
i would want to move so i would want to
move along the curve so i would
definitely want
i would definitely
want to get more rabbits i said that i'm
willing to pay a hundred berries for a
rabbit it would only cost me 20 berries
for a rabbit so i definitely am i'm
saying that i'm i want to get more
rabbits and another way to look at this
visually marginal benefit is is much
higher than marginal cost here so i'm
willing to go forth and try to get more
rabbits that's even true and scenario e
the marginal the marginal benefit of an
incremental rabbit is worth much more to
me than the marginal cost so i'm willing
to try to get more rabbits
so in scenario e i'm still trying to get
i'm still trying to get more rabbits i
still want to move along the
the production possibilities frontier in
this in this general direction
now what happens what happens when i'm
in what happens as i get closer to d so
if i'm in this scenario right over here
and this isn't one of our label
scenarios but if i'm right over there
still my marginal cost is lower than my
marginal benefit so i'll still want to
get more rabbits all the way until i'm
scenario d it's scenario d i'm a little
bit neutral i'm willing to pay 60
berries for a rabbit but that's exactly
how much i'd have to give up to get that
extra rabbit so let's just think about
scenario d for a little bit i'll just
circle it right over here because it
looks kind of interesting
now let's go now would we want to do
anything beyond scenario d
so if i'm at this point right over here
if i'm working enough on average to say
get two and a half rabbits a day
would i would i does this make sense for
me to try to get any more rabbits well
at that point the benefit of getting an
incremental rabbit is smaller than the
cost of getting a rabbit at that point
if i try to get another rabbit i'm
getting less benefit from it i'm getting
less benefit than the cost associated
with it so i definitely don't want to
move past d
so the i achieve allocative efficiency
where my marginal cost and my marginal
benefit is equal so the based on the way
that i've rigged the numbers in this
example right over here you want to
settle you want to settle on scenario d
we have achieved allocative efficiency
over there the marginal cost as a
function of our rabbits and the marginal
benefit of our function of rabbits is
equal